[Musica]
credi nei tuoi sogni non importa quanto
possano sembrare impossibili
Questa è una frase che campeggia
nell'aula magna di calarts l'università
fondata e voluta da Walt Disney negli
anni 60 dove ho avuto la fortuna di
passare qualche anno nella advisoryboard
l'importanza dei sogni
primo sogno che ricordo da bambino
è un lungo grande piano un prato verde
nel quale centinaia di bambini si
tengono per mano
e la sensazione è la sensazione di
grande gioia
giocano scherzano camminano corrono sul
fondo di questo prato c'è una foresta
con degli alberi di alto fusto nel mezzo
di questa fila di bambini ci sono io e
accanto a me una Brunetta che devo dire
mi piaceva parecchio
sulla sinistra la biondina ma quella non
me la ricordo meno
la mia vita quando ci ripenso è stata
proprio così una lunga camminata con
tante persone che mi hanno dato una mano
alcune per dei periodi più lunghi altri
per dei periodi più corti
e in questo percorso ho avuto la fortuna
anche di fare un mestiere che ho amato
moltissimo e che amo tuttora faccio
tuttora sono un famigerato banchiere da
fare
un mestiere che mi ha portato a girare
il mondo
un mestiere che mi ha fatto incontrare
alcune delle persone più interessanti
che in un certo modo decidono i destini
del mondo
capita azienda politici governi
e in questo ruolo ho girato
tante praterie vi ho girate tenendo per
mano mia moglie che tra l'altro qui in
prima fila e insieme a lei i nostri tre
figli due sono nate in Brasile a Rio de
Janeiro un altro New York
dopo tutti questi giri arriva il codice
siamo rientrati in Italia e tutto il
mondo si ferma
in quel momento credo che come tutti voi
mi sono chiesto se ci fosse qualcosa di
diverso a cui dovessi pensare rispetto
alle mille occupazioni giornaliere
in quel momento
credo che ricorderete tutti quella
serata di pioggia in piazza San Pietro
dove Papa Francesco ci dice non potete
pensare di vivere sani in un mondo
malato
contemporaneamente uno dei miei più cari
amici è ricoverato per il covil in
terapia intensiva gli manca l'ossigeno
allo stesso tempo
in un posto che con la mia famiglia
frequentiamo ormai da vent'anni un
paradiso verde si scatena un disastro
ecologico
e nell'arco di pochissimi anni 20
milioni di ulivi sulla superficie di
5000 km quadrati da delle distese verde
paradisiache diventano un deserto
in quel momento con degli amici
decidiamo di fondare la fondazione Silva
che si occupa di riforestazione voglio
farvi vedere un breve video che vi dà
un'idea di cosa è successo in quella
terra
[Musica]
a questo punto voglio raccontarvi le
poche cose in questi minuti che avremo
che ho imparato in tutti questi giri e
che in qualche maniera Ho cercato di
applicare nella creazione di della
fondazione Silva
la prima cosa credo che dobbiamo tutti
Tenere presente e che non c'è più
ossigeno da perdere questo è il motto
della fondazione ha a che vedere con
l'ossigeno questa risorsa che diamo per
scontata ma che in realtà è cosa ci
tiene in vita Voi sapete che la terra
potete immaginarla come un grosso
pallone immaginate di 12 metri di
diametro Beh non sono più di 3 o 4 mm
l'atmosfera terrestre piena di ossigeno
che semplicemente ci permette di vivere
sulla terra beh grazie all'anidride
carbonica Grazie all'inquinamento Ci
stiamo giocando questa risorsa e allora
non c'è più ossigeno da perdere Cosa
possiamo fare di fronte a questo
discorso due cose Una è la transizione
ecologica nel mio mestiere me ne occupo
praticamente tutti i giorni
tutte le industrie dovranno modificare i
loro atteggiamenti pensate alle macchine
tornando a diventare eletti che in tempo
rapido Ma questo discorso per mille
ragioni costerà molti soldi e ci sono
mille resistenze c'è una seconda cosa
ancora più potente ce lo dicono tutti
gli scienziati piantare alberi per darvi
l'idea di Quanto è potente questo
discorso ogni albero assorbenti dei
carboni che rilascia ossigeno sappiate
che a livello politico adesso che si
parla seriamente di cambiamento
climatico Macron ha annunciato la
settimana scorsa che vuole piantare in
Francia un miliardo di alberi un nostro
scienziato un'eccellenza mondiale
Stefano Mancuso ci dice che potremmo
ritardare la transizione ecologica
ritardare il cambiamento climatico se
piantassimo mille miliardi di alberi
quindi la missione nostra è che non c'è
più ossigeno da perdere e dobbiamo
piantare più alberi possibile Non solo
ma dobbiamo sensibilizzare Perché la
nostra cultura non ci ha portato lì
Sappiamo tutto sulla strada dell'uomo ma
di alberi sappiamo molto poco
la sfida è di quelle che fanno tremare i
polsi ma nulla è impossibile
stati anni fa il governo brasiliano mi
chiede di andare a trovare uno dei
personaggi più mitici un messicano dal
nome di Carlos Slim e la prima volta che
io sentii questa frase Nulla è
impossibile
lo senti in questo incontro con lui dove
io andrai a dirgli che l'offerta che lo
aveva fatto per questa azienda che era
celebrarsi le Ovviamente i Telecom
Italia era irricevibile e non era
possibile andare avanti Lui si alzò una
mano sulla spalla e mi disse Luigi con
cabeza corassonico hones
tutto è possibile
In pratica avete capito che con la testa
il cuore e credo che si dica coraggio
tutto è possibile
quindi lui aveva ragione infatti poi
ottenne quello che voleva ma se facciamo
quello che è successo proprio con il
covil uniamo tutti gli sforzi industria
politica Accademia e ci concentriamo
Così come abbiamo trovato i vaccini
troveremo la soluzione tecnologica anche
per il cambiamento climatico
quell'assorbimento di questa antide
carbonica in eccesso nell'aria che crea
l'effetto serra
nel frattempo cosa possiamo fare una
sola cosa tutti piantare alberi che ci
danno l'ombra e alberi che assorbe dei
carbonica e rilasciano ossigeno
cos'è il successo quando abbiamo fondato
Silva Ci siamo chiesti cos'è il successo
quando vado a intervistare delle persone
delle grandi università in giro per il
mondo
quattro su dieci dei ragazzi quando gli
chiedo cosa vuoi fare tra vent'anni mi
dicono vorrei avere avuto successo
la cosa paradossale è che il successo Se
ci pensate e il participio passato del
verbo succedere
e quindi è riferita al passato non al
futuro
l'altra cosa quando si parla di successo
interessante nel corso della mia vita io
ho notato che sono tre tipi di esseri
umani una prima che sono quelli che
amano fare succedere le cose
una seconda che sono quelli che amano
guardare quelli che fanno succedere le
cose e magari spesso criticarli
e c'è una terza
che forse quella Maggiore che si guarda
tra di loro e dicono ma cosa è successo
Ecco questa Se volete è la missione di
Silva fare succedere qualcosa
sensibilizzare sul importanza delle
piante per affrontare mitigare il
cambiamento climatico e piantare più
alberi possibile ovviamente Tenendo
presente le esigenze del territorio in
cui operiamo Abbiamo cominciato in
Salento Stiamo andando in Sicilia
andiamo da diverse altre parti perché la
missione è globale come tutto quello che
ha a che vedere con il cambiamento
climatico di che cosa avevamo bisogno
una squadra
e la squadra come sapete è una delle
cose più importanti Nel caso specifico
il famoso proverbio africano se vuoi
correre corri da solo ma se vuoi andare
lontano devi camminare insieme è
assolutamente applicabile Io questo l'ho
visto in tante manifestazioni nel corso
della mia vita ebbene la squadra che
abbiamo messo insieme per Silva è una
squadra straordinaria fatta di due di
e3u Vi chiederete
potrei dirvi e potrebbe essere banale
donne diversità
in realtà è fatta di sapere ascoltare
mettersi una porzione di ascolto per
capire quali sono le esigenze del
territorio ma anche le esigenze dei
diversi membri della squadra e per
quello ci vuole duttilità e ci vuole
dignità che deve essere data ogni membro
della scuola della squadra ma ci sono
anche le triumiltà
umiltà bisogna essere piccoli per poter
essere grandi
Voi direte come è possibile che un uomo
di 2 metri ci racconta staffetteria Beh
non l'ho detta io l'ho detta Papa
Francesco Di nuovo quindi me la
consentirete ma non solo umiltà ma
umanità è uno dei principi fondanti
della nostra fondazione dare una mano al
più debole e soprattutto umorismo Questa
è la terza o diffidate sempre me l'ha
insegnato di persone che non sanno
ridere soprattutto di se stessi
Ci siamo chiesti cosa vuol dire vincere
o perdere che quando immagini una
missione devi porti degli obiettivi
Ebbene Sappiate che nel corso della mia
esperienza di vita e professionale
vincerò perde in realtà non è il tema ho
vinto tanto ho perso tanto nessuno ha
vinto sempre e nessuno perde sempre a
volte Però succede che si vince in due
solo in due nel mio mestiere si tratta
di negoziazioni in una negoziazione uno
pensa ad aver vinto ma vi racconto
un'esperienza che mi è capitata nei
primissimi anni
abbiamo venduto per conto di una grande
famiglia italiana una grande azienda e
insieme al proprietario andammo a
festeggiare in un pub a Londra e mentre
festeggiavamo Ci sembrava di aver
raggiunto il prezzo migliore per
quell'operazione abbiamo venduto alla
grandissima esco mi avvio verso casa e
300 metri più in là in un altro pub vedo
uscire i compratori abbracciati Contenti
come se avessero vinto il campionato del
mondo in realtà erano loro che avevano
pensato di aver vinto erano loro che
pensavano avere strappato un ottimo
affare quindi lì capii una cosa
importante
al di là della percezione si deve
vincere in due in ogni negoziazione in
alcune partite Bisogna capire come si
può vincere tutti insieme o perdere
tutti insieme pensate al cambiamento
climatico e tutto il mondo che si gioca
una partita la stessa cosa La guerra
nucleare perderemo tutti Allora nel caso
della questione climatica a Silva Noi
siamo pronti a vincere questa partita
perché non possiamo perderla ne va della
nostra specie e in questo senso siamo
pronti a mettere insieme dei mondi che
troppo spesso non si parlano Io vengo
dalla finanza ma la industria la
politica
l'associazionismo troppo spesso
soprattutto nel nostro paese questi
mondi non si parlano visto che parliamo
della sopravvivenza della specie è
importante che si torni tutti insieme a
puntare la stessa direzione come si è
fatto per il covip esattamente così
e il nostro augurio è questo
infine
vivere per qualcosa che superi l'uomo
Questa è la vera missione della
fondazione Silva quando piangi un albero
sei perfettamente che quell'albero lo
stai piantando per le prossime
generazioni Non lo vedrai nel corso
della tua vita verranno forse i tuoi
figli ma poi lo vedranno i figli dei
tuoi figli e in questo senso è il senso
quasi spirituale di questa nostra
missione che ovviamente parte da una
cosa molto concreta dobbiamo piantare
degli alberi Ma si sviluppa nella nostra
testa verso l'infinito
e in questo senso il mio sogno che vi ho
raccontato all'inizio in realtà Adesso è
cambiato è in due sequenze nella prima
piantano questi bambini degli alberi di
piantano insieme a me di piantano
insieme a noi di Silva e qui questa sera
c'è un po' di amici di Silva
ma poi nella seconda sequenza io non ci
sono più
Ma ci sono i miei figli i figli dei loro
figli sotto questa foresta all'ombra e
il cambiamento climatico si è risolto
grazie
[Applauso]